هو دائما عندما ينظر الحقيقه المراه لواقع
المنطقه منطقه العارض يجد انه ربما بعض
الخصائص المميزه لهذه الجهه يعني نجدها
الخصائص المميزه ايضا من ناحيه الدينيه
مثلا نجد العدد الكبير ايضا من هؤلاء
العلماء الذين مروا على هذه المنطقه يعني
اذا كان في فتره الامام محمد بن سعود
تقريبا حصرنا العلماء من كتاب الشيخ عبد
الله بن بسام الذين في فتره الامام محمد
بن سعود قرابه الاربعه وتسعين الى المائه
عالم فقط في فتره الامام محمد بن سعود
هناك فترات ايضا سابقه قديمه ايضا لهؤلاء
العلماء وتواجدهم ايضا في هذه المنطقه لكن
كانت النظره الكبيره لدى المجتمع الحقيقه
تركز ايضا على هذا الجانب الذي نريد ان
نتطرق له وهو الجانب الامني الذي ارى الذي
استطع الامام